[Musique]
minute de silence demain dans tous les
établissements scolaires
à quelle heure comment ça va se passer
c'est en fin d'après midi nous laissons
les établissements les écoles
s'organiser de manière adaptée et aussi
anges ont pouvant choisir les modalités
c'est la minute de silence mais ça peut
être aussi une heure de discussion dans
le cadre de l'éducation morale et
civique d'ailleurs sur finalement ce
qu'il ya derrière cet événement tragique
il est aux alentours de 18 heures hier
lorsqu'un homme commence à semer la
terreur dans les rues de la ville de
cannes berg muni d'un arc ils tirent
dans la foule avec des flèches comme
celle-ci retrouver ici planté dans un
mur cinq personnes sont alors tué deux
autres sont grièvement blessés le
suspect le voici espen anderson braaten
déjà condamné pour avoir menacé de mort
un membre de sa famille et pour
cambriolage l'homme avait également été
surveillés par les services de
renseignement l'année dernière converti
à l'islam il aurait montré des signes de
radicalisation est la police tu es là tu
es a dû alors après on peut discuter
assassinat meurtre ou accident ou
bavures ou une police des polices qui
peut tuer parce qu'en fait tu as les
armes et surarmés et elle est dangereuse
les propos de monsieur poutou envers la
police ont insultant indignes d'un élu
de la république au nom du ministère et
pour défendre l'honneur de tous les
policiers je dépose plainte à chaque
fois qu'ils ont la possibilité de mettre
en cause la police ils mettent en cause
la police avec des arguments qui sont de
plus en plus indigne est de plus en plus
violents mais on savait que la campagne
électorale serait pourri et brutale ben
voilà illustration immédiatement
première interview sera média national
et le lendemain une plainte déposée par
un ministre contre des propos qu'on
exprime donc il ya un problème
démocratique est posé vous savez
pourquoi les viandes et pourquoi elle va
pour une raison simple c'est qu'il en va
du destin de la france et que il y à ces
gens ces élites françaises autour de
bernard henri lévy et des autres qui ont
depuis 40 ans
consciencieusement
culpabiliser la france pour mieux la
servir on va vous désormais parce que
bien entendu une arme létale nollet alou
intermédiaire le policier n'en a pas
besoin si on écoute un petit peu votre
vision du terrain et de la police et
puis vous nous ferez un retour
d'expérience et je vais vous dire ce
qu'il est monsieur bernard ollivier
c'est très simple depuis quarante ans
qu'il a écrit l'idéologie française il
est un traître il est la figure absolue
du traître madame dati c'est moi qui
parle et en l'occurrence même quand
j'étais prof à sarcelles les élèves se
taisait donc vous allez faire pareil
personne n'est dupe vous êtes à 4%
abonnés à 4% et vous n'irait pas plus
loin vous ne m'interrompez pas je m'en
fous madame je m'en fiche je n'en ai
strictement rien à faire madame vous
n'êtes pas là pour raconter votre vie
devant la faiblesse de votre candidature
le conseil de paris devienne tribune de
votre campagne électorale désespérée et
désespérante
fernand et lévis est un traître à la
france mais il a en plus le plus grand
fabricant d'antisémitisme qui soit au
monde c'est à dire que à chaque fois
qu'il parle les gens se mettent à avoir
réveillé leur antisémitisme
soignants qui a l'air de pousser le
président la république tiré au la
grosse pression
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'intérieur du pied aux autres le
gardien a triché clairement alors là
clairement il est riche et il pouvait
l'arrêter là on est vraiment dans le
ventre sans papiers qui se dit vaut
mieux pas que ce
but présidentielle pour un match de gala
au profit de l'opération pièces jaunes
aligné au sein de l'équipe du variétés
club de france emmanuel macron
positionné en milieu gauche récupérateur
a chaussé les crampons devant près de
2000 spectateurs qui posait la question
de savoir quelle couleur jouera les
adversaires ils sont jaunes je n'en dis
pas plus c est pour ça qu à quoi on joue
en gilet jaune